this is one of the officials at the  heart of ukraine's war effort and he's  confident of victory  but alexi danilov said the speed of  russia's defeat depends on how fast the  west delivers weapons  without western military support would  ukraine have been able to successfully  defend kiev in the way that you did  he showed me photographs of what he said  were syrians who'd been killed fighting  for russia sky news couldn't  independently verify the claim but  moscow has said it's recruiting fighters  from the middle east  society  [Music]  foreign  since russia launched its war on ukraine  the top official has been by his  president's side  the toughest of times but he says he's  not scared  you're still smiling like how was it how  my  debra haynes sky news keeve